this huge turnout shows that the
government's crackdown is not working
despite massive arrests in the past
weeks more people have gathered to
demand an end to police violence and ask
those detained to be released but
started as a local election protest has
turned now into a broader movement I'm
here to show that I'm tired of the
fascism of Moscow government against its
own people alexander solovyov is the
only opposition candidate who tried to
run in the Moscow election who is not in
detention at least not at the moment
before the rally we could only meet him
at a public square because he's avoiding
arrest by not going home he had been
detained for eight days after the
previous protest all the authoritarian
regimes collapse just because of their
actions like this because they do
everything vice-versa they suppress they
crackdown and they try to stop the
spread of information they stop they try
to stop something inevitable something
that you cannot sell they try to stop
time they tried to set progress the
detention of opposition leaders like
Ilya Yashin and Alexei Navalny
has not deterred people from taking to
the streets at the authorized rally
protestors were urged to take part in
another unauthorized rally that's where
police started to detain people and
again part of the center of Moscow is
under a lockdown
people are being detained for peacefully
marching here through the city centre it
was an authorized protest people are
being brought in one by one dragged over
the floor detained sometimes with quite
a lot of force people have been
screaming and resisting yet and they all
being brought into this class while
Vladimir Putin is celebrating his twenty
years in power
analysts say more Russians when their
voices to be heard the citizens are
demonstrating something brand-new and
you way of interacting during this
protests and importantly their
persistency it's not valued enough but
for a political process like this it's
the key factor so far the authorities
have not backed down
although less people were detained than
curing previous wings but with tens of
thousands on the street and more
protests expected pressure will only
grow step fasten al Jazeera Moscow